okay a little bit about me and my name's
primetime 99 alex stein that's kind of
my alter ego and what i do is i like to
go to city council meetings town hall
meetings school board meetings any sort
of public meeting and i like to go and
and do a form of entertainment called
culture jamming where i take the most
absurd parts of our culture and i try to
jam it in politicians faces so they'll
pay attention i started going to
meetings at the beginning of the
pandemic and i was talking seriously and
they didn't pay attention to me at all
and then i noticed the crazier i got the
more attention i got from these
politicians hello mayor my name is alex
stein and um you know after hearing that
testimony it just shows me that you know
las vegas is really not heading in a
good direction well there's multiple
reasons why i use these public meetings
first of all one of the first methods is
the fact they all stream it live stream
with a good overlay so it's like they
actually do a lot of the production work
so all i have to do is entertainment as
a performer i like that it makes it a
little easier and then also like i said
as these politicians you can't get their
attention if you go to these city
council meetings and i know in las vegas
you hear some crazy stuff from a lot of
the city's residents and they say you
know how the woman before me was
speaking about how she lived in her car
and how she went to social services and
they didn't help her and these
politicians basically ignore them and i
saw them personally looking at their
cell phone the whole time really not
paying attention to the needs of their
constituents these casinos give people
free drinks and then they become
vulnerable and end up gambling more
money than they have and i was a victim
of that and i lost a lot of money and
i'm facing a lot of issues right now my
wife's boyfriend recently got her
pregnant and i'm here for a church event
um speaking for i'm a member of the
church of scientology and i don't
normally drink but i'm very vulnerable
i'm in a position now where i don't know
what i'm going to do because financially
i'm going to have to take care of this
baby potentially because he's out
on parole right now and he has an
upcoming case where he could be facing a
long time in jail oftentimes these
politicians they don't like it they are
very thin skin and that will cause him
to react and since i'm basically a
professional troll uh you know i've kind
of created a new niche
of just trolling politicians in front of
their face at public meetings and i get
entirely way too intoxicated i go to the
atm i use my credit card they make it
very accessible to be able to gamble
with my credit card you know this mayor
goodman they make it absolutely
incredibly accessible councilman to be
able to take all i have
and now i got to go back to clearwater
florida and i have nothing
everything in vegas is super expensive
now i mean a hamburger is 32
but somehow all the vodka and red bull
you want as long as you're sitting at a
slot machine or sitting at a table is
free and for me i think that is a little
bit of a red flag and i want to bring
attention to that not saying that i
necessarily think it should be illegal
or stopped but i think it's something
that these politicians should address
that you know there's a lot of
vulnerable tourists to go to las vegas
and come back with nothing and the one
good thing about this city i will say
the one good thing is of all the cities
i've been to it's the first city last
night at 4 am i saw multiple people on
fremont street taking the vaccine that's
the only place i've seen a 24 7 vaccine
operation in the united states of
america yeah i'm all in i'm like andy
kaufman he's my comedic hero so i'm a
method actor i mean i practice a serious
methodology that when i'm in there i'm
on the grind all the time i want them to
drag me out i want there to be
confrontation i saw lots of people on
fremont street doing the vaccine and i
want to commend you the one thing but
the vulnerability of the tourists that
come here like myself
you're preying on people like me
and then i end up meeting a nice
filipino girl i take her back to my
hotel room
come to find out i cost money
for her service to come to my room mayor
goodman i want to applaud her she
actually had a good sense of humor she
was sitting up there smiling basically
the whole time if i had a cameraman i
would have gotten a reverse angle please
please you do have issues be calm and
just take one day at a time try to pay
for my wife's boyfriend's kid that's not
our responsibility sir they gave me all
the alcohol
but councilwoman fiore didn't have a
sense of humor at all
sir this is not the first council
meeting you have come into you actually
go through council meetings across the
united states and do this performance so
please leave our chambers at the moment
thank you
being serious doesn't work i'm not doing
this interview because i went and spoke
about something serious i'm doing this
interview because i went up there and i
went insane and that's how you get
people's attention you got to use in
this world that is an upside down clown
world you almost have to be the core
jester to get anybody's attention
you need to remove him marshall's remove
him right now
this is ridiculous goodbye
goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye
did you know what the deal is jesus
he needs help yeah well he does he
doesn't
have a chance
what happens in vegas doesn't say in
vegas i'm coming back to vegas i will be
back and definitely before mayor
goodman's done because i want to applaud
her and i kind of want to troll michelle
fiore a little more so i'll see i'll see
you councilwoman michelle fiore